[Music]
according to this he should be right
here so what's happening here
well that's me and that's my friend Aldo
no really his real name is Aldo I
checked his Costco card and everything I
don't know who you're thinking of but
this Aldo is an actor who sometimes
likes to hide around town and help me
test location sharing apps yeah it's
great
my whole life people have been adding a
W to the beginning of my name like it's
so funny anyway
apples find my friends location sharing
and Google Maps and an app called life
360 have become very popular amongst
groups of friends and families they all
work similarly you share your real-time
location with a person and maybe they
share it with you and then you can see
each other on a map right down to the
specific address yes it can be very very
precise creepy absolutely but there are
some good reasons to use these and if
you're convinced which one is best
that's why all those here wait where's
Aldo
[Music]
although has an iphone on him but those
three location sharing apps I requested
his location from each of the apps and
he accepted he also has the ability to
turn off location sharing with me at any
time but before we get into which one
works best let's consider why you may
want to track someone like Aldo or while
you may consider someone tracking you I
have two reasons number one meeting up
whether you're meeting a friend in the
park or at a restaurant you can see your
whereabouts instead of texting back and
forth Google and Apple let you limit the
sharing of your location to different
periods of time say an hour or two or
you can choose to share indefinitely
number two safety people use these
services to make sure friends have
gotten home okay in a cab or uber
parents use this with kids of all ages
focused on families the life 360 app has
features for tracking new drivers of
course there are plenty of reasons not
to track notably you give up your own
privacy and also you can get anxious
when the tech doesn't work right also
stalking yes the list goes on if you
decide to share your location make sure
it's with someone you know and trust
okay so which one is the best test one
standing still outside
let's see which of these lets me find
Aldo outside the easiest so all three of
them seem to have him in the same place
guess if I bear to the left here sort of
by the water
winner of test one found you never Apple
and life 360 they plotted him faster and
more precisely test two on the go but
what happens when Aldo is in a car or
horse each of the apps update location
at different intervals if you have
Apple's app open it will refresh every
minute when life 360 is open it
refreshes every three seconds making it
way easier to keep tabs on a moving
vehicle or animal yep it's coming across
Central Park South right now winner of
this round
life 360 life 360 and Google also show
you the remaining battery percentage of
the person you're tracking sadly Apple
doesn't test three inside a building yep
although decided to go to work today the
GPS can get close and give you an idea
of what indoor location someone is in
but often it puts them right outside it
on a map according to all three apps he
should be standing right here in the
middle of 47th Street winner none of
them they all plotted although in the
middle of the street your decision
should really come down to privacy
policies and what phone you have Apple's
policies are the best it retains your
location data for just two hours
Google's not so much it requires that
you enable a setting that lets Google
keep a record of every place you've been
it can use this data to show you more
targeted ads Google does offer a tool to
auto delete this data Lite 360s policy
says your data could be used for
advertising and there's no way to
currently delete your location data from
its servers if you've got friends and
family with iPhones and Android phones
go with life 360 I found it to be better
and faster than Google Maps if you've
got an iPhone and friends and family
with iPhones go with Apple's find my
friends or what's gonna be called find
my in iOS 13 I've decided to use find my
friends with some of the closest people
in my life which basically now makes me
Aldo
[Music]